hi everyone Sal Khan here from Khan
Academy and I just wanted to welcome you
to this course on Internet safety now
you might be saying why should I look at
this course the internet seems like this
fun and fabulous place where I can
interact with folks and get information
and do all these great things but you
also need to realize that the internet
can be a dangerous place there are
people who are going to want to get
access to your personally identifiable
information the things that would allow
folks to say take a credit card in your
name or pretend to be you or steal money
from you so you want to figure out how
do you protect that and we'll have a lot
more content on what exactly pii or
personally identifiable information is
as you know on the internet you have
many accounts it could be account for a
site that allows you to play video games
but it could be your banking account it
could be where you send emails from your
social media there are folks out there
that would love to have access to those
accounts they might be able to directly
do things on those accounts it could be
as little as embarrass you by taking
advantage of your social media account
or it could be stealing money from you
if it's your bank account or if you have
the same password in multiple places
well they might be able to use that from
one place to another
so beware of everything on the internet
you have a lot of information about
yourself that could be valuable to
others and you're also going to learn
that some of those folks are going to
try to trick you you're going to learn
about things like phishing attacks where
they're going to try to pretend to be
someone else and make you feel really
urgent about doing something and giving
information once again that you do not
want these folks to have so take a look
at this course it's going to be very
very important to you hopefully none of
this stuff ever happens to you but if it
does you'll know what to do about it but
even more importantly you're going to
know how to prevent it so hopefully you
enjoyed this course